[Music]
you have been lobbying the host Craig
Ferguson announced he's he's he's
stepping down Ferguson is stepping down
from the Late Late Show I want to take
that job you probably want that job I
know this job looks easy
it does look easy but do you think you
had in this job it looks hard no this
job looks easy okay
well I know it looks easy but do you
really think you've got the chops I'm
gonna use the phrase cha sure do you
think you got the chops to be a talk
show host oh yes you cuz there's a lot
of things you have to be able to do you
don't just sit here and go fall that's
98% of it do you have the chops to do it
no I've been studying it like a jesuis
excuse the j-word and I believe I could
do it in one minute you think Norm
Macdonald that in one minute you can
display all of the talk-show skills one
minute that's all I need if I want to
see this don't we
[Applause]
oh and then I say this yeah alright here
we go and now here's Norm Macdonald
[Applause]
thank you very much ladies gentlemen you
do you familiar to Maya they model Kate
Upton well apparently she told the
London Sun that life would be easier if
she had small breasts you know I suppose
that's true if by easier
she means harder we have a great show
yeah Hannity or however you know I
understand that you had a little trouble
your wife last night dinner yeah you
know I love she's she's a sassy sassy
gal and yeah and she's uh well let's get
to her first right
please welcome comedy legend Fred
Willard
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
every night I love your show I'm doing a
great job
we might heard you brought a cliff I did
my [ __ ]
sure yeah
[Applause]